ます
みなさんこんにちは
じゃあさんですましたなるんですが未だ義手んだろう
えーみなさん
おじゃ王者飲んでいらっしゃいません
そしてお茶を飲む時に幸せを感じていらっしゃいません
今日はですねテーマのプリ住む家はせて私の方ではいえブレンダーと
チャーという2つのぷりずむ館
俺本当に話しましたよ
[音楽]
行け私は皆さんに提案したいと思っている
いうのはあっ
お茶ねもっと幸せだろうはいう呼びかけです
私の本では良いブレンダーこれは
japan 関係してそしてそのチャーがの調合して味をつけるという仕事です
私の主なフィーのは
後者の良い
ですが私日本茶の中国茶の
そしてハーブ d も仕事で使いますし
ですから今日の話では皆さん
お茶お茶だけでなくお茶前半という意識でお話を聞いていただけるといいですね
木メンダーの仕事というのは何をしてい
簡単に例えると皆さん
ズボンの時間の稲葉を燃やしてください
パレットたを en 分
あガイアの業です
そしてそれを混ぜる
女サギができます
そして青多めにすれば
うん所様
なんかもしれな
ダメさになります
このように2つの素材を混ぜることもちろん約3でもいいです
混ぜることで
新しいもの
それからまたそれはもともと一のです
者に何パーセントと難破船と思えない
南米もゲームしておけば同じものが再現できます
まさにこれをお茶の家がを控えて考えていただくとそれが
意義ブレンダーがお仕事なわけです
n 部のように扱って君上るものを作る
同じ味新しい味そういったものを作ると見てしまうんです
に今回私が降り済むというゲームをとるぞ
これはキーブレンダーというリズムなんじゃないかなっ
演奏しましたん
いいブレンダーというプリー
お茶て光はで言うと
屈折してい
色々あり四季や色々なブレンドの講座が底から現れてくる
これはもちろんティーブレンダーの経験や技術が生み出しているわけです
何をに大事なのは
ティーブレンダーという人間
のせいだと思っ
そして私は自分の構成ということに
何自信ありましてま kop 二部が分で
you
ゲーム術方法とに
一番ひっかけだと思いますが
時間的に無理をしても部活を掛け持ちしてい
そして学外のサーブにもたくさん目にしていっ
今日は自分で応援されますが頑張れそう先生もう
に私の10倍だしオサーンの
もすごいそしてあのすごいぷリーディングが数
願っていただくようになったんです
の場所を探しています
イナゴの良いですね高校時代の活動
サークルでお茶を入れておいしいねうれしいありがとうと言ってくれたことで私は自分
の場所を見せた日になりました
そして大学在学中に良いパーギーの境内6サービス事業があります
講座専門家
西表紙御社の会社に出社として独立していままホテルやですからのメインなのに
ちょっと思い出すという企業でのは面白い学校で
すごく祈りを感じ
そしてみんな上昇志向が強い
それからな髪に噛まれた
はありません
そして位
も gc なっちゃうとわっ
をすればって瀬波ん
いや尊重してくれ
いそういう部分が勝ったからこそ自分の考え方や
どうも犬学
そんな風にもっ
そしてをやって地面だーがうりずんですっ
がお茶というのは
例えば一人いろいろな時間
あるいは家族と一緒に飲むものじゃ
そしてお祝いの席で飲むであっ
様々な感じ
ポンドはそうです様々なお茶というものはそれぞれが幸せを生むわけです
幸せは記憶が作ります
おさがわせが記憶もっ
釣り気温な幸せですがなっている
プロセスを考え方今度はお茶というのプリズムにしてみましょう
雑記やティーブレンダーといっしょ奉行をリズムにしましたがお茶プリズムにしてみる
とまた違ったものに
こういうのは世界中の小地域の生活軍馬という左は続けましょう
そうするとそこからは色々な輝きが出て例えば英国文化ですと
パターンいって
嬉しそうな声で食べてます
それから派
台湾などにいけな
1もむちゃげですねそしてインドにてば
中でいい店なんですけどいいちゃいいですか
日本のお茶
このようにですねジャニー世帯の文化を当てると
いろいろな1人が出ると
それぞれが間違っててどれが正しいということはない
それでそこの文化があってそれを理由にしてそういうを前になってい
そしてお茶という世界史でなんと一説によると音声排除のられてい
世界でお水の次に泊まれている神様とも言われていますね
何故かといえば簡単なことで
お茶にはいくつかの特質があります
代表的なのは昔は経験で今日は科学で分
言語に良いもの
そして安心してどこでもついて
第二でもねー
u 2が進んでいますし
雪やるの良いがおいしいことがあった
誰もインパクトの愛しばてでもいいんですね
ですからそうやって体に良くて誰も飲んでもおいしいものだ
それを
コミュニケーションツールとして機能したいです
ですからもてなしのせい
深大寺に者が流れてい
山田も言えるんじゃないでしょ
ところが本柱では
このお茶にチョップした陛下が追った
私は仕事上作用のでも心配しています
これ同じプリズムです同じお茶に同じ
諸地域の生活文化と光はでなんですが
実は生活文化に変化が訪れています
そして今のお茶にも変化がをする
これは情報や生産やいう2イン可児
例えば世界所の方に行っても
あのなぜの美味しいか血縁があって
同じ口座のメインとなっています
それから例えば
実際はたちも開発に関わっているんです
サンズをどれだけの素晴らしい香りの
光量を作るわけです
そうするとそのペットボトルの風車が
上手な人が一生懸命た後全員を
おいしいだったりするんです
者らにはねぇ
エッセイ会社はブログでお茶の所も始められてい
ものすごい数の専門店っていてたくさん記事を書いているのに
ある時お話しましたのが
本当に薄いって部分
ないんですよね
あれお手紙をいただいてい
石木ダムに入れなんですけれどもおいしいがどうかわかりませんでした
こういう質問もあったりします
それだけですに
実は日常生活の中の
いや ed ず
どこが出なくなって
n に扱えばいい
者が生んだ状況となっていいんじゃない
そういう心配も少ししています
ですから皆さんもう少しだけ意識してその時間を持っていませんだ
その意識してお茶の時間を持つというのはやはりコミュニケーションの中でお茶を飲む
ということが一番の返事だけは
さて私の仕事で復光会バーディ
話をすると
麻木の社員
にしかないんです
コツを教えてください
んですねっ
でもじゃあ判断です
影響はですね今者講座をやる予定できておりませんので細かなん
コツはお話ししません
まあグラビアに渡したのに静かに葉っぱ
そして
イケアが停止とのっ
江戸部に簡単の木版ですね
次回中どこに行ってもディーヴァー口への否定的に見られることも
100年も歴史があって
我々プロがその時代の最初ので蜘蛛の子を使っ
もっとも所年室が効率よくを意識で4
工夫しているんです
医学だけ上手に使っていただき
人ばかりへどうぞはい
お水が出てくるのある一番駄目ですね
うまくは降らない兄弟よろしくお願いします
でも御家から実はどうでもいいんです
第二山はいえば頼む水も結果駆使するはどのように内くん
ですから現在のスピード社会ファーストサービスを目指す中では
アンティレディ
どれ見ていますが
ペットボトル飲料や
みー2+
映像で打っているチャップアップ
入ったものも上席活用する猫な大事なんじゃないかと
お客様や友人家族そして何より自分自身
分
これはコミュニケーションですから
無事に
おいしいお茶を用意して楽しくん
視力人と止めこういうことが大事なんじゃないか
ですねこちらがと作ったコミュニケーションというの
とてもいいからな気持ち現実感を与えてくれ
ところがさっき話ししたとおり私は今
均質化が進んでいること
そして本質の位置が変わってきた併用が起こっていること
芸術団が薄れているんじゃないかと
心配しています
確かに我々の生活は豊かで安全である
技術
情報や流通がシーン化することはとても良いことだと思う
ですがその進化の
かわいいに
いわゆる寒いの向きで
実は底にある本当の感動です
本土のその気持ちと言うな
なってしまってい
悪魔にカタログ的に情報を集めることに追われてしまっているような
そういう気持ちも少し上げます
私が20世紀の多いにお茶にか運動して毎日見たり小説を読んだり音楽を聴い
そしてその方は21年生があって友だち外見という中で体験したことは
このを者と言うなっ
私が見に行っ
世界が私が世界を感じているからこそ
世界の美しいという高揚感
そして位
あとはもし私が死んでしまったとしても
一緒にお茶を飲んだメンバーが私のことを覚えていてくれ
彼らが生きている限り
世界に続いていくという案シーン
こういったもの私はを着分を通じたコミュニケーションになるから
得ることができました
ですからわたし自身はその気持ちを大事にしたいと思います
そんなもちろん
もありますが
世界史が一つになってしまったら
もう心配も反省もないもなかった
こういう女のあるかもしれません
私は言ってることがこれからもどんな
らしいが間違っていません
これは私には分かりません
ですな少なくとも私は今ホテルやレストランのお茶のメニューなどを作っていた
20シーンの世界デー
を際何ができるのか
そして20ページの末までに私が感動し的な
小里いうものは一体何だったんだろうか
こういう気持ちを常に米で仕事をするようにしています
今日はこの後ディセプションの時間に後ろ手に紅茶を入れながらみなさんと
監視したいと思う
まずはね美味しい魚ただみんな幸せになりましょうご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]